ich glaube meine lautstärke stimmt nicht
lull teams hat wieder zugeschlagen ich fasse es nicht, so eine kacke software alter
weirdchamp, bisschen groß vielleicht
so jetzt muss twitch nur noch verstehen dass das stream online ist
dann können wir weiter basteln
gucken wir mal das heute schaffen zumindest zumindest das gif in irgendeiner
art und weise zu rendern
auf twitch schickt den leuten eine benachrichtigung und sagt dass das stream online ist
aktuell habe ich einen zuschauer, oh nee jetzt sind sieben, jetzt sind sieben
vielleicht hat twitch jetzt was geschickt gerade und jemand da, kacke wait
ok twitch hat es kapiert alles klar nice, huge, big brain twitch time
alter irgendwie ist mein headset total verknotet, moment wo geht der kopfhörer jetzt lang
außen rum, unten drunter durch, ja perfekt
oh ich muss mal kurz in discord gucken ob der fabian was geschrieben hat
ja twitch hat es immer noch nicht gecheckt dass das stream on ist
ok twitch hat heute echt keinen bock zu sagen dass das stream online ist ich bin schon zwei
minuten dreißig da und es sind fünf zuschauer am start weil twitch, ah jetzt jetzt ich glaube
jetzt haben, ah ok jetzt haben sie es gecheckt gehe ich mal von aus
alles klar huge, moin leute oh gut es könnte auch daran liegen dass
freitag abend ist und keiner auf twitch unterwegs ist aber normalerweise kommen immer instant
zumindest ein paar vorbei
kann es elfmeter schießen aha ok ich gucke nicht so viel fußball das einzige was ich
letztens geguckt habe ist deutschland england das war mega resident sleeper bis zum schluss
und dann aber auf den sack gekriegt aber ehrlich gesagt hat mich das jetzt nicht großartig
interessiert moin leute endlich mal direkt x kam ja wieder wieder
wieder ekliges zeug hier ich mache schon mal kurz auf
der overlay champ ist am start der overlay champ will weitergebaut werden
i moment moment warum ist die schriftgröße so klein
monka font das muss ich gleich mal ein bisschen gleich mal ein bisschen anpassen das ist ja
geht das oh mein ja so nett na komm wir nehmen sogar mal das neue
jetbrains font mal 16 oder 18 18 komm huge fetter font alles klar
ich hör mich ja das gut kann ja sein kann ja sein dass ich immer erst ein bisschen so
in fahrt kommen muss ich hab übrigens heute was aufgenommen
aber das war mir zu spät um das noch hoch zu laden das ladest du wahrscheinlich morgen
erst hoch also für you to be gibt ja leute die youtube so aussprechen ich kenne da genau
einen legendäre hacker
oh ne simplicity muss es immer so krass übertrieben
das kann ich mir nicht angucken das funktioniert nicht
was haben wir hier ultimate doorbell die sind alle kacke deswegen habe ich da auch
keine geht es heute weiter ja hier da guck da sieht
auch genauso hässlich aus wie das letzte mal aufgehört
aber heute heute lesen wir das gif ein ob ich in irgendeiner art und weise das gif
gerendert bekomme und ich hoffe dass es mit transparenz keine
probleme gibt weil transparenz ist immer so eine sache
das ist rgb eigentlich richtig jetzt rgb ist out bgr ist das beste guck hier
bgr wir machen rgb ist out
achso mein testbild was die falschen farben hatte
ja gut das war hatte die falschen farben weil es halt nicht bgr ist sondern rgb
na dann muss man sich nicht wundern dass die farben verkehrt sind
ne ne wir machen das heute direkt mit ffm pack easy gar kein problem ffm pack gif
gif rendern und fertig kann ich betarte ml google hacken natürlich natürlich
du musst aber vorher du musst aber vorher noch irgendein hacker kollektiv
joinen dass du dann sagen kannst ha ha ha bin lizard squad oder hießen hießen
die typen nicht so hießen die nicht so die damals pama psn didost haben ha ha ha
lizard squad übrigens übrigens leute leute es gibt es gibt noch ein absolutes
keck keck triple u thema also richtig richtig richtig ist keck triple du thema
warte mal ich muss mal kurz das wobei die größe passt eigentlich ganz gut aber
ich war kurz bisschen kleiner richtig ist keck keck quadruple u thema und zwar
guckt euch das mal an habe ich letztes paar heise gelesen und zwar leit leit
aha moment ich bin es jetzt nicht muss mal kurz
wo ist es denn
ja ja also ich war ich weiß nicht welcher realitäts bremden substanzen
sich da irgendwie hingegeben haben bei so einer idee aber keine ahnung also ich
habe ich habe ich habe keinen platzen schimmer was dort los ist in welche ich
habe keine ahnung in welcher welt die leben what the fuck das hat ja mit der
realität überhaupt nichts zu tun aber wisst ihr ich habe ich da erst mal ein
bisschen aufgeregt hat mir gedacht wollte mich verarschen er die letzten
jahre ja das bild ist natürlich wieder richtig heckermann typisch aber die
letzten jahre überall wo es ging den den unternehmen das leben schwer gemacht
spiele schlecht geredet und jetzt wir wollen der leit war es auch übrigens
leitmarkt heißt wahrscheinlich leit mit d der leitmarkt ist das der leitet der
leitet ja also der leitet der der markt gut was auch immer die mit toxischen
community ist aber das weise der lacher der lacher der woche schon mal und die
die meinen die meinen das übrigens wirklich ernst ne ich habe ich habe mir
das hier mal angeguckt die haben einen pdf published weil sie wollen es die
richtig wissen die am pdf published das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht komplett an
weil das ist für den huge gelaber massive gelaber 36 seiten gelaber aber
aber wenn ich mir schon anguck wer am start ist er und ich habe gesagt keine
ahnung wer das ist fest also ich weiß dass sie da was genau was genau für für
für den posten hat sie zumindest das einzige woher ich die kennen ist weil
die beim gest beim letzten computer deutschen computer spiele preis in so
einem merkwürdigen rosa kleid rumgelaufen ist das ist das also so und
der deutsche computer spiele preis den erwähnen die hier auch noch guck mal
hier wir haben einen erfolgreichen computer und wo ist der preis hier
irgendwie verstanden was vom computer spiele preis gerade hier und und jedes
jahr vergeben wir gemeinsam mit dem verband der ganze branche game was als
kreativer name auch schon wieder ist discord bot tot weiß ich sollte er
hoffe ich nicht wenn ich muss der cute mod den mal wieder rejoinen lassen
nee twitch twitch ist allgemein grad lahm mit notifications verschicken so und
jetzt kommt den deutschen computer spiele preis der leute leute der deutsche
computer spiele preis der ist an lächerlichkeit kaum zu
überbieten wisst ihr welches game bestes multiplayer spiel geworden ist nicht
spoiler leute ich zeigte euch deutscher computer spiele preis 2020 oder war erst
21 gewinner gewinner okay okay alter was ist mit der seite los die sprocken ich
muss mal ganz hier da wieder ausmachen das geht damit nicht
multiplayer animal nee ja animal crossing ist bestes multiplayer spiel sind die die
sind nicht mal ganz bei sinnen den multiplayer spiel wurden
multiplayer nicht funktioniert wenn einer das spiel verlässt animal crossing
nintendo spiel als bestes multiplayer spiel ich mein es gab vielleicht dieses
jahr nicht so viel grantiose multiplayer spiel mag alles sein ja aber animal
crossing ein spiel was den spielstand verliert wenn bei einem die konsole
abkackt oder er oder er disconnected oder es sich milliarden probleme gibt dass
man zum beispiel auch zusammen überhaupt nichts machen kann oder der progress
nicht gespeichert wird bei einem also das zeigt auch mal dass dieser dass
dieser preis absolut lächerlich ist ich bin mir nicht sicher was es für geile
multiplayer spiele so gegeben hat letztes jahr war der war der eigentlich dieses
jahr schon ist auch immer so zu games kommen oder das sind die 15 an der war
schon im april irgendwann also animal crossing hat 2021 gewonnen ist animal
crossing nicht von 2020 20 was ist ein bestes multiplayer gewonnen aber es gab
es gab so viele
also ich meine es gab so viele multiplayer spiele 2020 so das reicht
ja wenn man google sucht ich meine hey wenn die schon ein nintendo spiel wenn
die schon ein nintendo spiel darf vergeben dann hätte auch meinetwegen
ich bin jetzt kein großer call of duty warzone fern aber da hätte ich aber
wenigstens warzone gewinnt das ist ein multiplayer spiel es hat auch seine
probleme aber es funktioniert in multiplayer auf jeden fall 1000 mal
besser oder hätten sie voll geist alter voll das ist zwar cheater verseuchten als
fack aber das ist ein multiplayer spiel was funktioniert ja mein wegen
velorant irgendwas alles bloß nicht animal crossing warum
warum wird ich krieg die seite ganz kurz kann ich mich immer wieder warum wird
animal crossing bestes multiplayer spiel das check schnitt naja das ist
vergesst also das ist wie gesagt so deutscher computerspiele preis ist so
ein lächerlichkeit eigentlich kaum zu überbiegen und da nehmen sie hier noch
bezug drauf und der rest ich habe nicht alles gelesen
bla bla bla bla bla bla bla bla irgendwelche rentner sind am start mit
controller bla bla bla bla also was ich was ich was ich vermute warum warum die
jetzt der meinung sind dass deutschland der leitmarkt für computerspiele werden
soll ist die wollen einfach ganz billig ein paar wehle abgreifen also ich glaube
die nehmen das nicht ernst also die wollen das auch nicht die haben auch
gar keinen plan und die wären auch gar nicht in der lage so was überhaupt zu
machen ich glaube die sagen einfach nur das
wort games dreimal in der hoffnung dass irgendwelche leute sie deswegen wählen
alles andere kann ich mir nicht vorstellen zumal das wieder so ein
typischer fall ist von das ist übrigens was was mir mega auf den sack geht es ist
egal ob das jetzt auf politischer ebene in der stadt ist im land ist im bund ist
es eigentlich vollkommen egal eine sache die mir mega auf den sack geht es dass da
immer irgendwelche sachen einfach random behauptet werden und man dann drei
jahre nichts hört und es ist vergessen ich meine wusstet ihr dass deutschland
angeblich bis frag mich nicht 2020 oder so führend weltweit führend werden
sollte bei digitalen behörden moment
nicht dass ich misserzähle ich zeige euch jetzt dass es das stimmt hier
oh sorry 2021 ja hat er nicht so ganz funktioniert würde ich mal behaupten
wenn unsere gesundheitshemmler mit corona immer noch faxe verschicken hat
nicht so ganz funktioniert ist halt wieder so ein punkt gewesen
wir haben es einfach mal gesagt einfach mal gesagt es hat keinerlei konsequenzen
du kannst irgendeinen scheiß erzählen vollkommen egal übrigens wir haben auch
bis 2018 50 mbit für jeden haushalt das haben wir ja auch darf er auch nicht
vergessen das ist ja alles alles andere wäre ja fake news so und das ist das
ist einfach das ist so peinlich es ist was man daran sieht ist dass sie
eigentlich von moderner technik absolut keine ahnung haben und das
schlimme ist das schlimme ist dass ich dass man es ihnen auch gar nicht mehr
zutraut mittlerweile man weiß ja ich weiß ja nicht wie es euch geht mein
erster reflex wenn ich so was lesen ist das hier oder besser gesagt eigentlich
mein erster reflex noch eher das ist mein erster reflex und das ist eigentlich
bitter wenn man sich das mal überlegt dass das erste was man denkt ist das
wird doch eh nix wurde schon über print nightwear da kann ich gleich was zu
sagen das ist eigentlich der witz dass das das erste ist woran man denkt und
das schlimme ist das schlimme ist man denkt das mittlerweile bei so viel wenn
ein neues bauprojekt vorgestellt wird ist das erste woran man denkt das wird
ja nichts leider ist das so habt ihr habt ihr was
flugtaxis wtf habt ihr habt ihr gelesen mit dieser komischen mit diesem
komischen bahnübergang der 50 jahre gedauert hat habe ich letztens habe ich
letztens news news 50 jahre bahn und unterführung hier habe ich genau bei der
hessenschau war unterführung 50 jahre 50 jahre
das muss man sich mal vorstellen vor 50 jahren es war 1970 richtig schnell für
so der unterführer oder 50 jahre da war mein opa 40 oder so ein opa wäre jetzt 90
geworden ja mein opa war damals 40 das kann ich gar nicht vorstellen
der lebt mittlerweile gar nicht mehr also das ist das sind auch so dinge und
wissen das ist das schlimme was ich weiß ich da immer habe egal was ist sei es
was mit neuer technik oder sei es irgendwelche bauvorhaben die
angekündigt werden ich denke immer automatisch ach das wird doch eh nix kann
auch nicht funktionen eigentlich ist es doof dass man das denkt weil man ganz im
ernst eigentlich hätten wir also geld hätten wir eh gar kein gar kein thema
eigentlich also wenn wir kein geld aber hat keiner geld und wir hätten
eigentlich auch die die leute dafür die fähig sind was ordentliches zu bauen aber
wir verwalten uns immer so tot und sind so krass ineffizient mit allem das
kann keiner bock hat was zu machen und es ist ja auch schon standard sorry dass
ich jetzt erst mal 50 halbe stunde rum rental wieder und es ist ja mittlerweile
schon standard dass sachen was wollte ich sagen was auch ja standard ist dass
irgendwelche sachen abgenickt werden von denen man weiß ok das wird teurer und
dann wird das nicht einfach nur einfach nur irgendwie mal 20 prozent teurer oder
so sondern das kostet am ende dann das fünffache oder so wo ich immer denke
was also jeder der da an der planung beteiligt werde war war und dem man
nachweisen kann oder wo man halt sieht da wurden sachen vernachlässigt weil
anders kann das ja nicht kann das ja nicht vorkommen
der sollte doch nie wieder was anfassen dürfen was ist das denn stell dir mal
vor du wirst irgendwo als projekt manager eingestellt und die sagen dir
du hast ein budget von 5 millionen machen machen und wir wollen das haben und du
sagst ja wohl easy ich bin ihr mann mit mir machen wir das in in zwei jahren
sind wir fertig so und dann sagst du nach drei jahren
ach leute also ich wollte eigentlich nach zwei jahren fertig sein hatte 50
millionen budget wir sind jetzt nach drei jahren übrigens noch nicht mal
halbfertig und wir brauchen übrigens 250 millionen die würden mich hochkant
instant kicken die will ich verklagen noch die würden mich ich würde meines
lebens nicht mehr froh werden weil ich so was machen würde vor allem wenn ich
halt die ganze zeit auch nichts nix richtig kommunizieren und sage so und
das ist vollkommen egal da kannst du irgendwas machen planen tun
scheiß drauf aber was das für eine unrealistische überschrift ja unsere
überlegt gerade was ist auch verkehr für verkehr und infrastruktur ich kann mir
das immer nicht merken unsere chefs sind der meinung deutschland wird soll der
globaler leitpunkt für computerspiele werden ist halt absolut lächerlich ist
kompletter witz also kannst du kannst du ja ich ich verstehe ich verstehe die
ganzen sachen nicht und das schlimme ist dass man eben schon automatisch denkt
es ist es ist es klappt ähnlich dabei wie gesagt wir hatten das geld werden
die leute wir haben auch genug fähige leute haben sie auch genug motivierte
leute aber du kannst der motiv du kannst die motivierteste person auf der
welt sein wenn du dich fünf jahre mit deutscher
bürokratie auseinandersetzen muss da bist du nicht mehr motiviert da hast du
einfach kein bock mehr irgendwas zu machen oder wenn du hörst dass
gesundheitsämter corona zahlen nicht richtig austauschen können weil fax
nicht geht oder so meine güte und wohlgemerkt fax 2021 sollten wir laut
dem was der altmaier 2017 erzählt hat eigentlich führend sein was digitale
behörden angeht aber es ist halt alles dumme dumme geschwätz was sollte ich
jetzt noch mal zeigen die trucker sicherheitslücke hier das da ja das
habe ich vorhin gelesen das habe ich vorhin gelesen ich habe nicht so genau
gecheckt wo wir gerade bei fax sind jetzt sind wir bei trucker ich habe das
vorhin gelesen ich habe es nicht so ganz gecheckt wie das ausnutzbar ist so wie
ich das verstanden habe sind wohl actif directory ad controller zum größten
teil betroffen juckt mich jetzt zumindest privat absolut nicht auf der
arbeit kümmere ich mich um die lundungskisten da juckt mich das auch nicht
ich glaube nicht dass das was remote ausnutzbar ist ich habe ich habe es
vorhin nur kurz überflogen
so wichtig bei sicherheitslücken ist immer man muss gucken wie die dinger
ausnutzbar sind ja also im prinzip muss sich daheim so wirklich akut erst mal
nur remote code execution interessieren beziehungsweise irgendwas was sie halt
reif bei im browser einfangen kannst gefolgt von quasi privilege escalation
für admin sonst was wo beispielsweise dein mailprogramm unsicher ist und
danach noch eine sicherheitslücke in windows ist dass der typo atmen werden kann so
und ich gehe mal davon aus dass wenn es hier um irgendwelche printer geschichten
geht das nicht aus dem internet so einfach auszunutzen ist es reicht wenn
der spooler remote erreichbar ist wie gut es ist aber niemand der fall daheim
also deine trucker warteschlange ist ja nicht irgendwie übers internet
erreichbar im in dem netzwerk sieht das schon wieder anders aus kannst du mir
kurz sagen was mit willi pete kars ist keine ahnung weiß ich hab keine ahnung
vor vier jahren bis letzt mal mit ihm keine ahnung weiß ich nicht
jetzt muss jetzt kommt wieder die chat message jetzt kommt die übliche chat
message wieder bei diesem song haben sich meine eltern kennengelernt der gag
kommt immer irgendjemand bringt den gag immer mittlerweile ist er aber schon so
abgelutscht ausgelutscht ne wohin ihr wisst was ich mein
so alle windows version bedroht warum schreibt heise nicht oben drüber kann
ausgenutzt werden also remote ist das remote alter heise artikel common
blies so
was nicht workaround das system abzusichern ok führen sie die
folgenden befehle als domain abgut das ist für mich lokal in gruppen things
mich lokal auch nicht also ich für mich sieht das nicht so aus als ist man da
als normaler benutzer daheim hinter irgendeinem router mit nutt oder sonst
was oder mit ordentlichen firewall betroffen solange solange die
irgendwelche drucker dienste nicht im internet angeboten werden was ja nur
hoffentlich keiner macht also wer irgendwelche port weiter leitung für
drucken aus dem internet hat der hat ja glaube ich den schussnummer gehört
also wer sowas macht da ist ja wirklich nur ganz dicht du hast nicht mal einen
drucker das macht nichts du kannst aber du kannst windows drucker drucker
warteschlange und gedürntes auch an haben ohne drucker und du kannst ja
immerhin in windows pdf drucken virtuell
ja besser das ist aber doch die typische das ist doch die typische
windows der windows fix einfach das ausschalten bis es gefixt ist ist ja
eigentlich auch das beste was man machen kann wobei ich sollte nicht sagen das
macht keiner gibt schon genug leute die das machen wenn man mal sucht wie viele
webcams im internet erreichbar sind ja zumindest mal kurz als zusammenfassung
für alle die beim letzten strom nicht dabei waren ich zeig mal kurz was ich
heute oder wo wir uns heute ein bisschen dran versuchen ich habe hier schon seit
paar jahren diese software im einsatz mit denen ich so overlay gif overlays
machen kann gif overlays sounds abspielen gifs mit sound abspielen alle
alle möglichen sachen so und das ist ein bisschen verbackt und zwar manche gifs
sind viel zu schnell zum beispiel hier so ist er so ist das das kacken gif
richtig aber wenn ich das anmache ist es hier viel zu schnell im overlay und
manche gifs die ein bisschen mehr bilder haben sind richtig langsam
passt mal ob ich klicke jetzt mal
so habt ihr gesehen also das braucht zu lang so das versuchen wir zu fixen wir
haben letztes mal nicht sonderlich viel hinbekommen ich mache mir übrigens mein
bild weg also was heißt nicht viel hinbekommen wir haben eigentlich letztes
mal relativ viel hinbekommen wir haben aus dem microsoft blog artikel uns
rausgesucht wie man mit direkt x bilder malt auf ein transparentes fenster
aktuell erkennt man nicht allzu viel außer dass ich transparentes fenster
habe ich habe transparentes fenster und mal ein rotes rotes viereck drauf das
alles aber das ist ein hardware beschleunigtes über die grafikkarte
gemaltes rotes viereck in einem transparenten fenster durch das man
übrigens durchklicken kann wie ihr seht so ist das was wir brauchen
so und heute nehme ich ffm pack lese mal ein gif ein und guck dass ich das gif in
das fenster rendern kann hoffentlich mit funktionierender
transparenz ich glaube ja nicht die transparenz funktioniert eigentlich nie
auf anheben wieso allerdings wo war die message jetzt
doch gerade was von macbook geschrieben ja ja der wachst wahrscheinlich
heißt sie nitro xd oder sowas nö warum ist man sollte das nehmen womit man
besten klarkommen das hat überhaupt keinen sinn zu sagen man macht linux
only man macht windows only man mag only man muss das nehmen was am
sinnvollsten ist und es gibt bereiche da ist windows nice es gibt bereiche das
linux nice auch mac und es gibt bereiche da ist ipads iphone android was auch
immer nice also ich habe die ich habe ja die kombination oder temple us wobei ich
dann ich wüsste in welchem bereich das wirklich nice ist zum beten vielleicht
keine ahnung wenn man dann wenn man da das machen will also ich benutze die
kombination aus windows als haus system linux als muss ich übrigens gerade die
vm anmachen linux als alles wo ich irgendwelche
technischen sachen machen muss also sprich irgendwas programmieren irgendwas
machen ich meine das sei windows only anwendungen die kann ich ja schlechte
unterländlungs programmieren so und als mobile endgeräte verwende ich aktuell
ein iphone und dann habe ich noch ein paar also habe ich noch ein ipad für mich
und werden so ein bisschen mehr gerätiger aber ich habe auch noch ein
paar android geräte also ich weiß schon also ich kann da schon einschätzen was
für was am sinnvollsten zu verwenden ist und ich bin mittlerweile zum schuss
gekommen es hat in kaum einem bereich sinn zu sagen ich zwinge mich jetzt
dazu das mit xy das mit diesem system zu machen wenn anderes besser dafür ist
eigentlich egal also einfach das nehmen was am besten so wenn du mit macbook am
besten klarkommst warum nicht seit wann writer unter windows seitdem der chat
letztens gesagt hat visual studio will keiner sehen ich soll rider verwenden
beziehungsweise ich habe gefragt macht doch nicht rare der rare parrot
normalerweise verwendet man kein uns auf aber wenn man z libraries aufrufen will
und so kommt man oftmals nicht drumherum
rast macht das ohne große runtime ja moment rast macht das anders
rast macht das anders dort net macht einen runtime check ob das array ob du
in den boundaries von dem array bist rast hat compiler magic die dich den code
es gar nicht kompilieren lässt wenn es feststellt dass du irgendwo einen
zugriff machst von dem es nicht weiß dass das element zu diesem zeitpunkt
noch oder schon existiert das sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche ansätze
deswegen ist rast auch only for big brain leute weil mit rast bist du viel
beschäftigt dich rum zu ärgern bis es kompiliert aber wenn es kompiliert dann
macht es der regel auch das was du programmiert hast
was ist mit dynamic das eine gute frage dynamic ist das gleiche dynamic ist das
gleiche das ist nicht unsafe dynamic ist nur dass es zur runtime guckt oder dass
es erst zur runtime guckt ob die sachen da sind also du kannst zum beispiel so
was hier machen dynamic blub gleich eins und dann kannst du darauf aufrufen oder
oder ja irgendwie sowas sondern dann kannst du darauf aufrufen keine ahnung
heck weh und es lässt sich das kompilieren obwohl den int keine
methode keck weh hat also das lässt sich kompilieren ausführen mit dynamics
kein problem der guckt dann zur runtime eben erst ob es das gibt ist zum
beispiel ganz praktisch wenn du irgendwelche jason sachen passt und keine
extra typen anlegen willst für die response dann sagst du einfach dynamic
und greift dann so wie in ruby beißen oder sonst wie drauf zu verwendet man
relativ selten aber dort wo man es braucht ist es ganz praktisch aber
dynamic ist dynamic ist nicht unsafe dynamic ist runtime overhead gucken was
da ist ob es da ist so also zahle ffm pack zeug parrot einlesen jetzt habe ich
nur das problem ich muss ffm pack runterladen
gut pass gleich wo lege ich denn ffm pack in irgendwo hier in mein
verzeichnis ffm pack ffm pack download windows
die eigentliche seite die ffm pack downloads angeboten hat für windows ist
mittlerweile down aber ich glaube es gibt eine neue
dann halbwegs offizielle was denn davon besser die jahre def oder quake die
seite sehr hässlich atmar ok gibt's ffm pack nicht als nur get ich glaube nicht
du hast den rapper ach doch guck mal an das ist ja tschibet ffm pack nightly
aber von von 2020 na toll gibt's ffm pack doch guck mal da
411 was ist in stable stable was ist in die stable ffm pack version hier 4 na
geil na geil gibt es da eben das da irgendwas
aktuelles 4 4 4 2 oder ist ffm release version ja stable
was ist das für eine benahmung das ist versionsnummer kommet nach tech und
letzte kommet hasch und alter mein üde jetzt übertreibt seit man nicht aber
wenn es ist als wenn es ist als nougat gibt wäre natürlich cooler aber es sieht
nicht so aus als gäbe es das
4 3 wir laden das wir laden das von hand runter
welches welches davon brauche ich denn überhaupt die frage ist brauche ich in
x64 x86
wahrscheinlich egal
welches davon ist denn jetzt das richtige
schert wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich schert ich brauche da wo die wo die dls drin sind ja das hier
brauche ich ok passt wie sie also dann kopieren wir das mal hier rein
so wir müssen wahrscheinlich dann auch umstellen die cpu architektur auf auf
64 bit wenn es 64 ist sonst sonst mag er nicht ffm pack bin ok alles klar ich gehe
mal davon aus dass wir den fahrt hier brauchen also probieren wir das mal aus
immer fort hier unten root pass ffm pack bin so gucken wir mal ob ffm pack
läuft ob es kräft es kräft unable to load av format 850
auf legt es jetzt am name oder legt das jetzt an der architektur
wartet mal wie kann ich das hier umstellen den writer das mache ich
sonst nicht wie stelle ich den writer um auf auf
166 bet am herkommt da ne
jedes
die back
ja das ist eine gute plattform was rechtsklick rechtsklick im projekt
ah ah k64 spam warum heißt das übrigens noch warum heißt das dann noch ist das macht das das jetzt
richtig das heißt er immer noch any cpu ne ne ich glaube das ist irgendwas anderes oder
ok leute ich habe keine ahnung wie das funktioniert ich bin mal ich ich cheat
ich cheat jetzt mal schnell ich mache das mal kurz in visual studio auf da weiß ich
nehme ich wo das wieder wo das steht overlay jam ja für wampack version ist zu neu ne ich
glaube nicht ich glaube nicht ich glaube das liegt an der falschen cpu architektur
ja die datei heißt anders das stimmt das heißt aber nichts das kann auch an der
näher das kann auch an der cpu architektur liegen das mit dem name ist naheliegend aber
mal abwarten ach die wampack version ist heute rausgekommen ok dann dann ist vielleicht doch
ein bisschen zu neu ich stelle das jetzt mal kurz um any cpu wo ging das jetzt hier noch
mal edit new cpu x64 any cpu ok x64 alles klar so fuck es geht tatsächlich nicht ok
die version ist zu neu nehmen wir noch ein bisschen ältere ne das ist das ist nicht die ist nicht zu
neu das ist einfach ein daily build stimmt stimmt lasst mal gucken was ist es für eine exception
genau das dl not found ok also ich habe ich habe für 4 4 ich habe für 4 4 das richtige das
passt wenn das mal 58 das wäre bescheu das näher dann schon so einfachen dingern
ist das hier eigentlich fünf für den link ffm pack
holt das taum geladet ich nehm euch zeigt mal ja
die ist wirklich zu neu guck mal das ist die version von der anderen seite da heißt das
ding noch 58 ach das sind daily builds das ist wahrscheinlich schon 45 oder so was ja
nicht die sind wirklich zu neu die sind einfach einfach zu neu das ist nicht stable das ist
ein daily build ok dann können wir das dann wird es jetzt auch einfach funktionieren dann
kann ich den ganzen camp jetzt wegschmeißen und jetzt soll es hoffentlich funktionieren
ffm pack so schauen wir mal so wir haben umgestellt auf x64 starten und und geht
nice funst alles gut sehr schön jetzt muss ich rider plus noch weiter was was ist hier los muss
ich weiter plus noch dazu überreden das auch zu starten mit 64 bit funktioniert macht standardmäßig
cpu architektur ok funktioniert alles die version war einfach zu neu so also jetzt lesen wir mal
das gift an weil wir müssen extra wir müssen extra extra thread aufmachen sonst geht das nicht
pass run man ist die easy variante so pass run tru ja man ist die only only big brain
variante sollte in jede bewerbung schreiben dass man das so macht und jetzt lesen wir die
ganzen bilder ein go to schimpf wir machen go to wir machen einfach keine weilschleife was was
macht ok das ist jetzt ein bisschen schwierig zu erklären das da ist eine anonyme funktion
also ich könnte auch so was hier machen private us private void weg und dann könnte ich hier
einfach sagen hier starte quer que das wird auch funktionieren aber nachdem ich das nur an einer
stelle also starte quer quer in dem neuen thread alles was hier drinne steht aber nachdem ich das
nur an der stelle brauche kann ich das auch anonym machen hier würden parameter reinkommen wenn du
welche brauchst das kürzer ja gibt es einen unterschied zwischen thread sleep und task delay
das eine funktioniert nur erst ein gewählten das andere so aber task delay ist ungenauer als
thread sleep weil task delay über über den ganz normalen thread pool geht und das fragt
mir nicht task handling und thread sleep ist blocked halt den kompletten thread ist halt ist
halt ressourcentechnisch für den arsch aber mit einem thread sollte das sollte das verkraften
sein ok ich werde jetzt ich werde jetzt die die die frames oder die einzelnen bilder von
dem gif einlesen ich kopiere mir das jetzt dass ich das jetzt nicht neu basteln muss ich kopiere
mir das von was anderem raus und dann erkläre ich was ist was es macht also folgendes ffm pack
mags was programmierst du einfach ich zeig es mal schnell ich habe hier dieses tool wo ich meine
overlays mit immer macht wo man die bilder und gifs und sounds und so overlayen kann
und das hat ein paar bugs zum beispiel manche gifs sind zu schnell und manche gifs ich klicke
jetzt mal laden ewig lahm das ist eine zusammen haben zusammenarbeit warum das so lahm ist zwischen
wpf und wahrscheinlich dem der gif komponente die ich verwende deswegen habe ich gedacht wir
machen das jetzt einfach selbst wir rendern die gifs jetzt einfach selbst easy wie man was
rendert habe ich schon raus gekriegt mit direkt 2d das habe ich im letzten stream gemacht jetzt
müssen wir noch da irgendwie das gif rein bekommen hast du eine empfehlung für eine library für den
rest api windows service in c-sharp was ein rest api windows service willst du quasi sicherheitslücken
nachprogrammieren oder wie warum alles in der welt muss das alles gut laufen aber wenn du eine
wenn du eine einfache einfache restgeschichte verwenden willst kann ich dir empfehlen warte
wenn es geht warte auf dotnet 6 weil in dotnet 6 bauen die genauso was ein in dotnet 6 kannst
du minimal api machen für net 6 minima minimal api das ist eigentlich wirklich ganz nice
guck in dotnet kannst du sowas hier machen das ist alles muss nicht als hut laufen soll
aber den windows dienst sein da der webserver auf dem windows system laufen soll ja moment
moment moment moment moment dann ist dann ist dann ist dann ist einfacher dann dann ist einfacher
nehmen ganz normales asp.net core das hat einen webserver eingebaut du musst das nur noch starten
und dann ist gut das hat einen webserver dabei also irgendwelche ies geschichten oder so würde ich
gar nicht mehr mit anfangen ich würde eine asp.net core anwendung machen und die einfach starten
und dann funktioniert sie die an einen eingebauten webserver der auch ziemlich gut ist aber wenn du
wirklich ein minimal api machen willst kann ich dir kann ich dir das nur empfehlen guck dir mal die
sachen die mit dotnet 6 kommen an das ist quasi fast schon so kurz wie eine ruby sinatra anwendung
oder oder oder was was gibt es in python mäßig vergleichbare so flask oder so was ist was leute
was ist denn für für für für python die beliebteste so minimal minimal webserver sowas
wie express für javascript flask immer noch das einzige was ich kenne ne jango ist garantiert
nicht für minimal für minimal web anwendung gedacht jango ist huge manch einer würde sogar
sagen bloatet ne axios ist in kleinzeit javascript abfrage tool mein vor minimale
back-end-server mit was sowas wie express in javascript das express in python quasi
so also weiter weiter im text
menschen die ihre erste klammer in eine neue zeit machen sind ich sehe es umgedreht wisst ihr
was für mich dessen der hässlichste style von klammern ist so sucht jetzt nach deutsch klammern
moment moment das weine ich nicht if else
hier alter wenn ich das sehe das hier das ist für mich so also ich kann ich kann es kaum
beschreiben das sieht so schmerzhaft aus das ist so eklig bei mir muss die klammer also ich
lasse es mir noch gefallen ich lasse also ich lasse mir das noch gefallen wenn man so schreiben
würde also wenn man das so machen würde wäre mir natürlich am liebsten ja aber so lasse ich mir
noch gefallen aber dann wenigstens das else auf eine neue seite auf eine neue zeile aber das else
in die gleiche borne ne ne ne ne das mag ich nicht ich finde das ich finde die ich finde das
so viel an viel viel besser das ist sowieso ein anti pattern moment moment ist jetzt schon plaudit
oder was ok wer weiß was die aktuellen programmier gurus auf youtube wieder so verzapfen aber mir
waren nicht bewusst dass else schon plaudit ist es ist das jetzt so stimmt das stimmt das chat ist
als jetzt plaud neuerdings also wir machen wir machen einfach wir machen einfach if only else
brauchen wir nicht wir machen einfach nur noch if und dann return ne asb.net kreuz doch nicht
pains champ das ist eines der besten web frameworks auch kein if mehr das heißt wir machen noch
go to oder noch switch switch switch case oder wir machen nur noch wir machen nur noch inline
assembler jump ja genau so captain pang das habe ich mir auch gerade gedacht nur noch nur noch so easy
nur noch switch statements so also wir machen jetzt mal wir machen es mal weiter also ffm pack
ffm pack ist importiert funktioniert so was es jetzt macht ist folgendes das öffnet das gif und
zwar hiermit das öffnet das gif und guckt was da drinne ist dann guckt es dass das das erste
video aus dem gif nimmt also ich meine das erste video in dem gif ist das einzige video in dem
gif gifs unterstützen nicht mehrere mehrere videospuren aber in dem fall das erste video in
dem in dem gif feilen nehmen wir also ist halt quasi unsere gif animation dann suchen wir den
passenden decoder für einen gif decoder der das halt versteht wie so ein gif funktioniert und dann
starten wir das gif und lesen hier an der stelle das gif bild für bild aus und wenn wir fertig
sind fangen wir wieder vorne an also sprich wir lesen das gif aus und wenn wir das gif bis zum
ende eingelesen haben dann kommt ein fehler nämlich end of file und dann fangen wir einfach wieder
von vorne an also das heißt wir lesen endlos das gif ein bild für bild so das macht das so hier
sorgt er noch dafür dass die dass das bild das gif die code wird und dann haben wir es in rgb und
am ende wird das ganze wieder gelöscht dass wir keinen memory leak haben das ist alles mehr brauchen
wir in ffm pack wahrscheinlich nicht so wie ich das jetzt sehe steht hier in av frame steht jetzt das
packet und können aus der schleife raus wahrscheinlich nee doch doch könnten sie aber
da müsste ich anders machen da müsste ich immer hier davor noch einen clear oder sowas machen
ist wurscht ich lasse es jetzt so weil er weiß dass es funktioniert das habe ich jetzt vor was
anderem raus kopiert was ist denn das störnchen das da das ist ein pointer das ist unsafe c sharp
da darf man pointers machen muss ich in dem fall machen weil es eine c library ist und die macht
halt gerne pointer geschissen übrigens wir können das schreiben kann man nicht doch kann man so also
jetzt gucken wir mal ob das einlesen von den frames funktioniert keck weh gucken wir mal wenn
als ganz oft keck weh in der konsole kommt das funktioniert ja funktioniert ok alles klar so
und jetzt müssen wir mal schauen in welchem format also welches ab also in welchem pixel format das
gif vorlegt weil unser passt mal auf jetzt wird es eklig jetzt klappe ich mal das direkt x zeug
auf unser direkt x zeug sagt dass unsere bilder in bg ra format vorliegen das bedeutet zuerst
die blauen pixel dann die grünen pixel und dann die roten pixel und dann in alpha channel was
transparent ist bg ra ist für die coolen leute rgb ist für nups also wenn ihr rgb ram habt dann
solltet ihr den schnellsten ersetzen durch bg ra ram so also jetzt gehen wir mal aus was das
ding für ein farbformat hat ich glaube das ist pixel ne fmt ne format ok alles klar so da kommt
den int raus weil das ding weil ffm pack inkonsistenter crap ist das müssen wir
casten zu dem pixel format dass es funktioniert so mal schauen welchem format das vorliegt
ich weiß dass es bg ra ist aber ich zeig es euch noch mal so guck also unser gif liegt schon im
passenden pixel format vor das ist schon mal gut das heißt wir können potenziell unsere bilder
aus dem gif auch irgendwie rendern im im fenster also es ist kompatibel wäre dieses während die
bilder jetzt rgb dann müsste ich erst rgb zu bg ra also nein nein nein dann müsste ich rgb
a zu bg ra wandeln alles klar oder easy aber muss ich nicht weil es ist schon im richtigen pixel
format gut so und jetzt ist natürlich nur die frage wie kriege ich jetzt das von hier in
unseren in unser direkt x geschäft rein ich muss es wieder aus kommentieren wo render ich
denn hier noch mal hier render ich mein dreieck da da render ich mein dreieck hier render ich
aber soll aber ich drei hier mein mein mein rechteck wird hier gerendert das heißt ich mach das jetzt so
ja das ist halt hässlich als fack ich habe das letzte mal einfach so untereinander kopiert
wir müssen das glaube ich ein bisschen auslagern damit ich das noch verwenden kann also das müssen
wir auslagern sonst klappt das nicht das muss das eigentlich muss das hier rein aber das wird dann
dann blick ich dann blick ich selbst nicht mehr durch wir machen jetzt einfach hier sowas wie
das machen wir nicht ich mache das jetzt wirklich hier rein weil ich einfach nur testen wird ob es
funktioniert also ich brauche das die weiß und das brauche ich in der variabler dass es funktioniert
ok wunderbar also was brauche ich was brauche ich die swap chain und das d 2d die weiß kontext
alles klar wo leg ich denn das an d 2d die weiß kontext ach nee kann man das mal das
kommt man doch hier schön umbenennen anders nein hallo rename underscore ja war und jetzt
hielt perfekt so und das ganze jetzt noch wusste ich tausche jetzt mal aus als bräuchte die
swap chain noch wer denkt ich weiß was ich mache ich weiß es nicht wo ist das da ok und
hier müssen wir jetzt auch noch umbenennen als ich unten drauf zugreifen kann so zack alles gut
ok von der idee her sollte man jetzt noch nix sehen am gif aber es sollte auch nicht
kraschen wenn ich es richtig gemacht habe ich glaube aber es krascht ich glaube aber es
krascht leute ich glaube es ist kipp funktioniert nicht mehr ist kaputt was habe ich verkehrt gemacht
was habe ich kaputt gemacht es funktioniert nicht mehr funktioniert das dann prinzipiell
so das geht nee der rendert gar nicht der kackt ab der kackt ab guckt kann es euch
kann es euch zeigen dass der abkackt try catch drum herum ich habe es irgendwie kaputt gemacht
bei catch drum herum das ist ja das ist wenn aus forms aber wir machen eh alles selbst
guckt da was objekte reference not set to an instance warum wo ist wo wo wo was habe
ich verkehrt gemacht forms zeile 136 die weiß kontext
alter ich bin ja doof guck mal nee doch das ist das ist noch gar nicht angelegt wenn ich
das wenn ich das andere start moment moment moment hier ich muss das starten nachdem der
ganze mist angelegt ist ja es halt ist halt toll wenn man so so schönen gut sich selbst
dokumentierte software programmiert hat ja jetzt funktioniert ok und jetzt gucken wir
irgendwie das gift da reinkriegen ach du große scheiße wie kriegen wir jetzt das gift da
rein ich mache das das try catch wieder weg ok wie kriegen wir jetzt das gift rein also
wir haben das gift wir haben das gift hier wir haben das gift als wir haben das gift
im ram stehen das das aktuelle bild von dem gift haben wir als bgr a bitmap im ram stehen
ich hätte das mit mit haskell bauen sollen genau funktionare oder oder oder oder noch
besser ich hätte wahrscheinlich direkt den kobold machen soll im chat oder so das heißt
den ganzen mist kann ich mir jetzt eigentlich schenken wobei ich lasse das mal drawend kommt
hier runter wir wollen jetzt wir wollen ein bitmap malen wie kriege ich einen bitmap ich
weiß dass es ein draw bitmap gibt das problem ist nur ich brauche ein bitmap objekt dafür
was ich nicht habe ich habe das bitmap im ram so aber wir haben das letzte mal ja schon
festgestellt nee nee ich bin bisschen länger als 22 da heute wir haben das letzte mal ja
schon festgestellt dass man bitmaps kopieren kann also innen direkt 2d bitmap aus dem ram
rein kopieren kann so und das heißt ich muss mal kurz gucken ob ich irgendwie sowas habe
habe ich nicht ich muss ich mal schauen also wir müssen jetzt irgendwie den direkt 2d
bitmap erstellen also irgendwas was wahrscheinlich kopiert er das in den ram von der grafikkarte
vermute ich mal ich gehe mal davon aus wir müssen jetzt irgendwie das aus dem ram vom
vom normalen arbeitsspeicher in den ram von der grafikkarte kopieren irgendwie das bild
damit ich das rendern kann würde ich jetzt mal vermuten was es unter der haube macht
aber ich weiß es nicht also wir brauchen nicht draw mit mir wir wollen create create bitmap
create bitmap und zwar size ok size ist einfach size kriege ich raus size habe ich hier frame
breite frame höhe ok warum was hat er jetzt für schmerzen what the fuck also wenn auch
nicht mal sei es funktioniert es ist vielleicht falscher typ oder so das eine float und das
brauchen int oder was juckt ihn überhaupt nicht size so dann brauchen wir einen pointer
zu dem start zu der start adresse in meinem ram wo das bitmap liegt wie kriege ich die
wo liegt die hier ich glaube data heißt das data ich mache jetzt einfach maß ich bin
mir relativ sicher dass das so prinzipiell ging mit ffmpeg genau so data ach nee das
ist jetzt was ist denn das jetzt was da rauskommt in ein pointer oder ich bin bin verwirrt data
ist es nicht ist es nicht ziemlich monac s hier das ganze was ist also das ist ein beider
den beid beid pointer ja wie kriege ich den beid wie kriegt man ein beid pointer zu einem
in pointer in also eine managed in pointer so ah guck mal so so exzellent alles klar als
nächstes brauchen wir wie groß oder wie viel wie viel bit ist eine zeile also eine
wie kriege ich denn das jetzt raus na gut breite mal vier eigentlich oder es müsste ja breite
mal mal vier sein oder man eigentlich breite mal vier weil weil es ist es ist bgra pixel
format das heißt wir haben einen roten einen grünen einen blauen pixel und alpha channel
so und das ganze mal breite also wir haben vier mal breite vom bild das jetzt klappt
ok ok die können wir uns kopieren die kommt die haben wir hier oben irgendwie die können
wir uns kopieren hier bitte mehr properties alles klar leute wenn das das läuft im leben
nicht wirklich ich sage ich weiß ich sage das oft aber ich glaube das wird nicht auf
an die funktion so das kann man wegschmeißen ok alles klar zack haben wir ein bitmap erstellt
was hat er für schmerzen ist not assignable es sei warum was hat er für was hat er für
schmerzen aber muss ein ref sein warum auch immer weil weil direkt x zeug wir können
prädikten ja prädikten wobei wir können auch nicht prädikten weil ich habe ich noch
nicht fertig basteln ja macht man macht man macht man macht man macht man eine abstimmung
ne ne ne ne ne kanal punkto vote please mods und einfach nur wenn ich es jetzt starte nachdem
ich fertig basteln bin wenn ich das erste mal starte ob es crashed also ob es geht oder
nicht müsste das nicht mehr sein 255 ich habe keinen schimmer ich habe wirklich keine
ich probiere es jetzt ich mal ich mal jetzt einfach mal was wir probieren es jetzt einfach
mal aus also das mache ich übrigens hier oben schon mal nicht in nicht in draw sondern
davor so als wir malen jetzt wir malen jetzt eine groote rotes viereck das heißt wir machen
jetzt kein rotes viereck sondern wir sagen jetzt die weiß kontext trauer bitmap und dann
hauen wir dort das bitmap am moment hier haben wir dort das bitmap rein mit sollten wir gucken
ob es funktioniert jetzt sehen wir gleich ob es funktioniert du meinst breite firma ja du hast
recht du hast recht ja ja ne ach so doch doch doch doch wartet mal ja stimmt es ist ein
beid es ist vier mal es ist vier mal also es sind ja ja stimmt das recht das recht also 32
32 mal seite ok was sagt die vorhersage 50 50
kräftes ja nein ok ob das kräft es wird wahrscheinlich funktionieren ok nicht
das kann überhaupt nicht kraschen ok kraschen ich kraschen ist wenn wenn dieser thread krascht also
kommt das komplette programm wird wahrscheinlich nicht kraschen aber wenn der thread krascht
but will maus ok es krascht es krascht es krascht komplett krepp komplett krepp
krepp ok da muss ich jetzt da muss jetzt mal nach dem beton mal googeln av frame
was linesize stimmt da war irgendwas mit linesize die berechnen das schon für mich
linesize brauche ich genau ich erinnere mich linesize muss das sein genau ich
muss den kram gar nicht selbst ausrechnen frame frame linesize brauche ich und dann
glaube auch null jawoll ok next funktioniert es ist viel zu schnell ja ja gut von irgendwelchen
timings reden wir jetzt erst mal gar nicht und es ist noch nicht mal sonderlich optimiert
das legt jedes mal einen neuen bitmap an das hat komische konsolen ausgaben das ist die
back und ich habe sogar noch ein sleep von 16 sekunden drinne wie viele fps weiß ich
nicht kann ich kann ich kann ich aber was ich schon sehe ist die transparenz fehlt
transparenz funktioniert das nicht das fände das mit der transparenz funktioniert wunderbar
auch mit auch mit meinem viereck hier nur mit dem bild funktioniert das ganze nicht guck mal
ich mache das mal größer und den lassen wir irgendwie keine ahnung da anfangen es hier
seht also wenn ich selbst male das funktioniert wunderbar die selbstgemalten dinge mit transparenz
nur mein gif ist nicht transparenz kann ffmpeg alpha ja ja ja guck ich kann dir zeigen dass
das prinzipiell funktioniert wir spielen das einfach mit ffmpeg ab da wirst du sehen dass
das wobei ich weiß ich ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung ob ffplay das kann ffplay kann es nicht
aber ich weiß dass es funktioniert also da ist alpha drinne in der in dem bild also wenn
ich das guck mal ich machs mal ich machs mal im browser auf ich machs mal im browser auf
dann dann dann dann seht ihr es wartet mal was denn hier g ist den browser sieht man das auch
nicht richtig aber allein schon das einmal der hintergrund schwarz und einmal weiß war
seht ihr dass es alpha alpha channel dabei hat dass das bild ist richtig dass das da
mache ich mir keine gedanken darum das ist das gleiche bild was ich hier verwende guckt
das ist das gleiche bild was ich jetzt hier schon verwende das hat alpha channel drin
jetzt ist nur die große preis frage wie krieg ich das transparent also mal davon abgesehen
dass es mega hässlich ist was ich hier gebastelt aber wie krieg ich den scheiß transparent
reichschirm frage was wie krieg wollen wir mal gucken wie schneller maximal rendern kann
ich mache einfach mal das lieb raus wir gucken mal wie schnell er maximal ist okay wie viel
wie viel cpu braucht der jetzt aber wo ist es denn hier der overlay champ naja geht doch
gucke mal 6 prozent cpu und und 3,5 prozent grafikkarte geht doch geht doch bitmap make
transparent hat das sowas make transparent nee ich glaube make make make transparent
ist eben so eine so eine farbe die so eine key farbe die dann transparent ist nee nee
das brauche ich nicht nee nee ich habe ja den extra alpha channel der für transparent
zuständig ist ich habe bloß keine ahnung wie ich direkt 2d sage dass er das malen soll
mit mit transparent ich sage ihm ja das bild das bild wisst ihr was das ist einfach das
falsche format das ist einfach das falsche format ich sage dem dass mein bild alpha mode
pre multiplied ist es gibt irgendwie zwei verschiedene modi ich kann ich kann es euch
nicht genau erklären wie das wie das funktioniert also du hast rgb das sind deine farben für
das bild und du hast einen alpha channel und der alpha channel sagt wie transparent ein
pixel ist so und jetzt gibt es die variante entweder ist der alpha ist quasi das alpha
zeug schon eingerechnet in das rgb oder es ist als eigener alpha channel und du musst
danach irgendwie frag mich nicht es gibt pre multiplied und es gibt straight hat nichts
mit copper pride zu tun so und wahrscheinlich ist das nicht wahrscheinlich sage ich ihm
es ist pre multiplied und mit straight wird es nicht funktionieren aber es ist gar nicht
pre multiplied was heißen würde dass ich das von hand pre multiply muss ich habe keine
ahnung wie ich das mache es ist ja ja das ist bgra format das ist richtig also da ist
auf jeden fall alpha mit dabei wie mal ich das denn jetzt alter keine ahnung ok google
wir fragen google draw bitmap alpha ja selbst wenn selbst wenn die maps einfach ist ich
weiß gar nicht wie ich das auf dem komp für das komplette bild machen würde kannst du
den alpha channel mal auf null setzen ich glaube ich kann da gar nichts dran machen
großartig nee ich kann er kann er kann er kann er kann er gar nichts nee ich müsste
da genau ich müsste den schleife drüber machen habe ich kein back kein bock how to
draw bitmap alpha values bitmap nee nee nee das wollen wir nicht wir machen wir direkt
2d noch dabei how to create transparent bitmap good news nick you are creating transparent
mein das ist doch der gleiche das ist doch das gleiche blog post den wir auch schon verwendet
haben für das letzte super ganz toll deck overflow doch gif gif scheint einen separaten
alpha channel zu haben weil er sagt das bild format ist bgra das kann ja sein dass er das
der decoder von dem gif schon richtig konvertiert hat eben in bgra was das gif hat ist egal
ich habe ja die ich habe das ja im ram liegen als bitmap da ist ja schon gif ist ja schon
weg straw was zum mach was macht der du da die code was wick was ist wick was ist wick
der wick image viewer wick bitmap meine güt ist wenn also das ist das ist ein fass ohne
boden dieser diese wind aus direkt 2d geschichte da create bitmap from wick bitmap wick factory
ich brauche eine wick factory was ich will keine wick factory ich will ffm pack verwenden
das da das hatten wir doch schon das hatten wir doch eben schon offen oder ist was anderes
was zum nee das ist das ist das ist gdi das ist noch was anderes das ist alles windows
toich questions moment moment wir haben hier poggers link i am looking for a child as transparency
clear color was was alpha mode ignore what ignore gibt es wird doch nicht funktionieren
doch nicht aber wir haben schon mal hyper hyper speed beim rendern übrigens ich sehe
es gerade im stream im stream sieht man das überhaupt nicht man man sieht im stream überhaupt
nicht wie schnell das rendert das rennt gerade mit irgendwie 800 fps oder so make transparent
ist ja einfach irgendeine farbe die transparent macht das funktioniert nicht guck mal ich
ich glaube man sieht das im stream gar nicht ah doch meine vorschau zeigt es bloß nicht
richtig an so ich habe kein ich habe ernsthaft absolut keine ahnung ich das hier krieg wie
wie multiply ich das jetzt hat das das ist das hat einen alpha channel jaja ich glaube
aber also ich glaube es ist alles richtig nur dass ich die das das ffm pack das als
bg ra zurück gibt und ich brauche es als bg ra pre multiply so das heißt ich muss mich
jetzt irgendwie muss pre multiply selbst komm man ich hab keine ahnung wie das funktioniert
da gibt es auch da gibt es auch bestimmt irgendwas hier direkt 2d pre multiply re multiplizieren
von effekten alles klar re multiplizieren von effekten alles verwenden sie die auf englisch
lesen erst mal use this effect to convert an image aha aha from un pre multiplied alpha
das ist das wie unser bild ist to pre multiplied pre multiplied alpha so und wie geht das jetzt
effekt cls ad pre multiply was zum gibt es da gibt es einen example für vielleicht ich
ich ich brauche ein example get up please aha pre multiply ja das ist die gleiche seit
die wir vor hatten id 2d 1 effekt wie kriege ich das angelegt was id 2d effekt ok das
gibt es wie moment wie legt man das jetzt an pass auf big brain time example ach du
kacke ok also erst mal was machen die hier create effekt ich probiere das jetzt einfach
mal 2d create effekt so was brauchen wir da ah jetzt brauchen wir die id von diesem effekt
re multiplizieren oh guck mal geht das so ach du scheiße warte mal was zum wie was will
das von mir ok wie soll ich das benutzen new aha device context effekt so output ich habe
keine ahnung was ich mache ich habe absolut keinen blassen schwamm set input das stand
da was das stand fast von set input oder irgendwie source set value set value what
die 2 ok ok index index null ich weiß wirklich nicht was ich da angebe input ist unser bitmap
muss man das das das das pausen danach ja das dann lassen wir das für deine ram freigeben
danach automatisch so index null das bild raw bool invalidate ja klar true logisch was
sonst tru tru null weh kein keine ahnung was raw invalidate alles klar zu wissen mal bescheid
effekt haben wir alles tru image tru image und dann tru image und dann den effekt das
jetzt funktioniert es geht easy easy dazu kann ich nur sagen mir war von anfang an
vollkommen klar dass ich das richtige macht logisch ich habe einfach nur so getan als
wüsste ich nett so aber dass das auch nicht mal krascht ich hätte eigentlich gedacht dass es
zumindest mal in einer stelle ich muss übrigens mit visual studio noch mal starten weil ich
gucken will wie viel ram ob wir irgendwelche memory leaks haben oder so das nicht so gut
würde ich sagen leichtes memory leak ganz kleines wir haben schon vier gigabyte ram voll ich
brech mal ab das ist ich glaube das ist gar nicht so all gar nicht so schwer an
irgendeiner stelle ach so guck mal ich lösche guck mal ist doch ganz klar ich lösche das
bitmap doch nie so aber man using davor und dann ist das memory leak weg guckt easy memory
leak gefixt was ist das ziel schnell transparente gifs rendern und das mit dem schnell rendern
funktioniert ja auch schon mal irgendwie es ist so schnell dass man das bild nicht erkennen
kann bisschen steigt immer noch ja müssen wir mal warten bis der garbage collector garbage
collector läuft so das war erst mal in ordnung ok was mache ich hier was was ist das überhaupt
also so wie ich jetzt verstehe ist es ist das ist das folgendermaßen übrigens ich muss
noch ich muss das noch klären weil ansonsten malter immer oben drüber und dann sieht das
kacke aus guck mal so ist jetzt viel besser seht ihr jetzt jetzt löscht er das nämlich
im hintergrund
also so wie ich das jetzt verstehe ist funktioniert das folgendermaßen ich benutze ffmpeg zum
decoden vom gif dann kriege ich von ffmpeg im ram ein bitmap halt rgb oder bgr mit alpha
channel sondern sag ich direkt x ich hätte gerne ich würde gerne nen bild rendern in
diesem format also ne blau achtbit grün achtbit rot achtbit alpha channel achtbit was auch
immer u norm ist weiß einer von euch keine ahnung weiß ich was u was gibt es sonst noch
u norm typeless was auch immer u norm und definiert ne oder so und ich sage direkt x halt hey mein
mein alpha channel also das was transparent ist vom bild das liegt in pre multiplied vor
was auch immer es genau ist irgendeine art und weise wie man die pixel speichert wie
wie transparent welcher pixel ist warum benutze nicht a png weil ich das bild also weil gif
halt nun mal ein gif ist und kein a png so und das problem ist das ffmpeg das bild also
ich sage direkt x das bild ist pre multiplied der alpha channel ist es aber nicht so und
anscheinend haben die was eingebaut für so noobs wie mich dass man nämlich über die
grafika ich vermute mal das geht auf der grafikkarte dass man über die grafikkarte das bild quasi
dann pre multiply lassen kann und dann ausgeben soweit verstehe ich das es ist sicherlich
wahnsinnig unoptimiert noch weil ich lege ubs ich lege zb jedes mal dieses bitmap an
eigentlich würde es reichen wenn ich das bitmap nur einmal anlege wir können mal kurz
gucken wie viel er jetzt verbraucht naja ist doch kaum was wir lassen es gerade mal
ein bisschen größer noch ein bisschen größer rendern moment das bild ist einfach nicht
größer und ich muss das ich scale das jetzt noch mal kann man das scaling auf offset target
warum ist der hintergrund schwarz der ist nicht schwarz der ist transparent guck das transparent
wie kann ich dem sagen dass er das jetzt scaled auf die fenster auf die fenstergröße straw
sind hier zur auswahl das war das war eine konsolenfenster ja target offset gibt es wie
wie skaliere ich das wie skaliere ich das jetzt auf die fenstergröße das bild von
ich rede ja von gar nicht mehr dass das seitenverhältnis stimmt einfach nur dass die dass das bild korrekt
groß ist target offset brauche ich nicht straw image wie mache ich wie skaliere ich das jetzt
mal kurz so ja ich weiß ja weil ich kann sagen wenn ich sagen draw bitmap draw bitmap
ist einfach da kann ich sagen ich möchte destination rectangle so also sprich da kann
ich sagen wie groß es sein soll im ziel aber bei draw image kann ich das nicht ich muss
das ganze jetzt noch irgendwie skalieren ich habe keine ahnung wie target offset ist ja
nur da wo ich es anzeige ne wusste nicht dass man direkt in google suchen kann die code ffm
pack einmal alle frames oder jedes mal jedes mal jedes mal also wie gesagt das ist nicht
sonderlich optimal der decoded jeden frame und dann fängt er wieder von vorne an jeden
frame zu decode was jetzt bei so einem kleinen gift wahrscheinlich nicht sonderlich schlimmes
habe ich denn noch ein sleep im ffm pack drin ich bin ja hier beim ffm pack wie wie wie
scale ich das jetzt ich habe ernsthaft kein ok truim wir suchen jetzt einfach mal truimage
truimage scale canvas truimage direkt 2d das gibt einen scale effekt ich brauche jetzt
einen extra effekt zum scale oder was zum 1ks mein gott warum warum ist c++ so hässlich
gamma transfer scale ich brauche einen extra scale effekt oder was autoscale ich wäre ja
froh wenn das autoscaled das scale überhaupt nicht auto boah das ist mir jetzt zu big big
point scale effekt ok wir machen jetzt ein scale effekt scale effekt easy einfach ausbrücken
scale effekt alles gar kannst du deinen bmp direkt größer generieren lassen nee also
ich könnte mit ffm pack scale lassen aber das wäre ein cpu und das ist doof das scale
darf schön meine grafikkarte machen also gibt es denn gibt es dann scale hier scale effekt
using war scale effekt und da brauchen wir als input nix oder doch hallo hä achso new
ja aber bis ich ffm pack beigebracht habe gpu accelerate zu upscale ich glaube dann
geht das hier schon besser das funktioniert nicht so einfach das funktioniert nicht so
einfach wie man sich das vorstellt du kannst ffm pack relativ einfach sagen du willst beim
encode oder beim decoden die grafikkarte verwenden aber jetzt bei einem gift decoder sagen mach
mal ein upscaling über die grafikkarte das ist was das geht bestimmt das ist aber wahrscheinlich
noch komplizierter als hier ok jetzt muss man irgendwie das device eingeben scale effekt
dann nennen wir das mal um es ist nicht scale effekt das ist pre multiply hallo ich war
noch nicht fertig ich war noch nicht fertig alter ob ihr passt jetzt ich bin gar nicht
in der lage ist ok set input das das ergibt ja sinn so ich mache jetzt pre multiply und
jetzt sage ich scale so wenn das jetzt funktioniert wie ich mir das vorstelle sage ich da jetzt
input und zwar den pre multiply effekt ok das funktioniert nicht ach ne index eins wahrscheinlich
muss ich jetzt angeben in welcher reinfolge er das ausführt hallo true lulvee das funktioniert
nicht ach du große scheiße wie geht das wie wie wie wie wie chлавier solche set set value
ich hatte noch eben etwas auf stackoverflow wo ist mein stackoverflow vorneben gewesen
oder vielleicht mache ich das richtig vielleicht ist es ja sogar richtig
vielleicht stimmt das ja auch so so und wie sage ich dem scale effect jetzt das
das gelten soll ja set in mein gott wie kryptisch wie kryptisch kann man das
eigentlich bitteschön noch machen muss man muss man da vielleicht immer null
machen wie kryptisch kann man das bitteschön noch machen alter set value
ich hatte doch eben den stack overflow der was von gezeigt hat
müsste es nicht get output doch wenn es so was gibt gibt es nicht ich habe keine
ahnung ich hab kein schmuck set set value was so
ah what the fuck die 2d 1 scale scale ok
wo ist das kram wo ist das kram drinne scale 2d effects effects
boah keine ahnung was muss ich brauche ich brauche einen e-namen für index
wie funktioniert das scheiß ich habe wirklich nicht den hauch einer ahnung
wieder kam funktioniert die scale scale scale gibt es irgendwas
ach guck mal es gibt noch extra scale ne das ist meiner
boah ne das ist mir zu das wird zu big brain alter das ist gibt es hier ein
output oder gibt es tatsächlich output perfekt poggers wie sage ich dem jetzt
dass das gelten soll wir gucken mal wir gucken ob das überhaupt jetzt
funktionieren würde scale effect begin draws gel effekt
ist das problem aber ich bin ja falsch hier image soll man gucken ob das jetzt
überhaupt noch laufen würde oder ob es jetzt gleich krascht ok es läuft noch
was es gab scale
oder ach guck mal da man kann das man braucht den ganzen mist gar nicht
border mode center point ok was ok so das ist jetzt das ist jetzt der
faktor um wie viel ich das skaliere oder nee das ist das das ist an welchem
punkt er das geld ja direkt in der mitte würde ich sagen direkt direkt in
da und das wäre jetzt oben links keine ahnung scale und wie sage ich ihm jetzt
um wie viel er das ganze skalieren soll value a value wahrscheinlich einfach
value und einfach zwei jetzt klappt
hey das das geld ja wirklich ich meine stimmt zwar hinten und vorne nicht wie
es geld aber aber es galt macht es fetter
das funktioniert ok wunderbar der das ganze ist immer noch ein bisschen schnell
minimal zu schnell
aber es ist schon mal größer wie viel wie viel cpu brauche jetzt wie viel gpu
brauche jetzt aber kommen wir sind es teilweise 7 7 prozent gpu leistung einem
jinx elf monat langstiftens ab mach mal die lehrer ein ja kann ich machen hier
bisschen bisschen langsamer
50 weiß nicht wie viel fps das ding hat das kann man auch auslesen
ja ja man kann das man kann die fps auslesen ist überhaupt kein problem und
das dann ausrechnen ok ok dann mache ich mal kurz das rote das rote viereck da
weg das brauchen wir ja nicht so jetzt ist nur noch die große preisfrage wie
kriege ich das jetzt passend passend zum fenster ok wir machen das wir machen
das fenster mal machen das fenster mal größer
kann man ihm sagen fullscreen wird das oder maximize oder so wie maximiert man
den windows form fenster form was form windows state ne windows state ja gleich
maximis ok so ich den plus noch sagen dass er das nicht einfach doppelt doppelt
skaliert sondern da muss ich jetzt selbst rechnen das ist mir das ist ja doof kann
man nicht einfach sagen skalier mir das auf das wird wahrscheinlich nicht
funktionieren wenn ich dem sach nehmen nehmen mal reite und nehmen mal höhe das
wird nicht funktionieren da skaliert das jetzt viel viel viel zu groß das
funktioniert nicht
die da habe ich jetzt wirklich keinen plan wie kriege ich das
wie heißt ja wie heißt der shit den ich da verwende muss doch einfach nur ziel
durch aktuell machen und das in zahlen ach so stimmt stimmt ihr habt recht
höhebreite durch die giftgröße was hat jetzt für schmerzen possible wurscht
das stimmt das ist richtig ich habe nur das nicht richtig rescale das ist
korrekt das ist richtig so ihr könnt euch vorstellen wenn das größer wäre ich
muss jetzt nur noch sagen dass mein bild größer ist ich muss es einfach
maximieren wo ich den kram anlege
habe ich hartcoded irgendwie größer oder so drin
was ist das standardmäßig für eine größe
da das kann ich hier nicht hin machen das kann ich erst machen nachdem die form
offen ist hier das ist natürlich doof oder ich
müsste es heißen noch implementieren aber da habe ich heute echt kein bau
drauf bei 900 das kommt doch hin die breite breite kommt nicht hin ich
meine ich kann einfach mal reinschreiben 1920 mal 1080 das hat ja nix zack was
noch überhaupt nicht funktioniert ist ich weiß gar nicht warum dass ich jetzt
überhaupt am resizen stört aber das funktioniert so pixel format machen wir
mal raus huge parrot so dann probiert es noch mal
andere geschichte wie groß mache ich denn mein mein bitmap hier gar nicht
warum moment also weil er ist schon ein bitmap erstellt war so groß ist wie
man ist waptschein ok ich glaube ich gebe nirgends woanders da größe größe und
breite an oder legt es jedes mal neu an naja ok
so achtung leute epilepsie warnung so auslastung hier nix nix braucht es nix
nix das ist mal das war hyper high performance gif
übrigens ist klar warum das hier anpasst ich muss ihm sagen nicht die breite die
breite vom fenster sondern die breite von dem was ich mal was ich da angelegt
habe so
jetzt jetzt spackt es auch nicht warum beim resize also ich meine das
resizen ist ja noch noch überhaupt nicht implementiert wenn es da
resizen da ist einfach immer immer gleich groß jetzt
wir gucken mal wie schnell wir gucken mal wie schnell der wird der wird gemp ist
ich gucke mal wie schnell der wird gemp ist im neuen hier braucht der wird
gemp richtig lange ich klicke drauf und es hört gar nicht auf
mein problem ist ich weiß nicht wo es gespeichert ist wo wo
wo speichert web application elf die bilder keine ahnung web application elf
ok wo ist das
stimmt ja wir können ja hier gucken und dann irgendwo hier muss es irgendwo hier
muss es rumliegen die bag wo wo wo wo wo wo habe ich die bilder sind nicht in der
datenbank das weiß ich data
das ist nur uralte dort net anwendung guck mal hier 461 null
sehen wir mal wie alt das schon ist ja wo speicher ich denn meine bilder da nicht
da und ich schaue doch im konter da gucke ich nicht rein da da gucke ich
nicht mehr rein
was gibt ist das das ist das das bild was so lahm ist ok dann nehme ich das
einfach wird weird camping desktop jawoll
bäm alles klar dann nehmen wir das jetzt auch das nicht neu rarer
guck mal hier wie schnell das geht
denn das wie schnell das lädt im vergleich zu dem anderen meine die
aspect ratio passt nicht so wirklich aber es funktioniert es geht es geht es
geht richtig schnell im vergleich zum mann guck mal da starten bambild ist da
easy richtig richtig richtig zackig
ist es 1080p hardcoded ja nicht pro klick pro incoming moment klick pro
input incoming sieht so aus das ist jetzt komplett pro oder wird es dir
schlecht bei wenn du dahin guckst monach es aber das ist rider das ist nicht
intelli j aber das ist auch das ist das ist quasi intelli j für c-sharp das ist
auch von jet brains die die c-sharp idee
genau
jetzt werden wir jetzt natürlich quickmaps technisch auf zack werden
könnten wir noch ausrechnen dass der aspect ratio richtig scale effekt macht
aber vielleicht gibt es ja sogar schon eingebaut ist winforms besser als wpf
für solche apps ja also es ist ja gar kein winforms es ist ja im prinzip das
einzige was ich von winforms verwende ist dass der standardmäßig ein fenster
aufmacht ansonsten verwende ich ja nicht davon
ansonsten ist ja alles selber gerendert aber ja ist in dem fall ist es sogar mit
wpf kontraproduktiv weil wpf selbst versucht irgendwelche x render
geschichten zu machen und winforms ist total einfach du sagst dir einfach
create du musst mir einfach nur sagen winforms leg mich render einfach gar
nix fertig und die rest musste selbst machen also
muss alles so und mit wpf ist es komplizierter also mit wpf geht das gar
nicht so was du kannst natürlich du kannst natürlich versuchen den wpf
renderer zu überreden mit seinen 60 fps dann immer passen deine gifs rein zu
rendern das heißt du musstest dann irgendwie gucken dass du direkt x
interop mit wpf machst und so was aber wozu auch immer hier tschüss mein
name ist weiß weiß bescheid probiert es jetzt einfach kannst du nicht über den
forms elettronen gif einbinden
kann doch ja könnte könnte ich ich glaube image ich glaube die image box
kann picture box kann gifs da ist aber zwei
probleme transparenz funktioniert nicht gescheit und es ist lahm as fuck
weil das alles cpu gerendert ist aber allein schon als transparenz nicht
richtig funktioniert ist größtes problem
deswegen machen wir das selbst
jetzt haben wir das hier ausgerechnet was soll ich damit jetzt machen achso
warte mal wo bin ich jetzt gerade stehen geblieben was was wollte ich denn
sie machen achso dass die aspect aspect ratio richtig ja gut und weiter
quickmaps krieg ich heute im kopf echt nicht hin
muss ich das muss ich das jetzt damit mal noch mal rechnen oder ich bin da zu
müde für jetzt das krieg ich jetzt nicht geblieben
muss ich das mal nehmen oder
jetzt echt so einfach ist es ja 0w
glaube ich erst wenn ich sehe
darf ich fragen was du in deinem rechner verbaut hast ja kannst du
kannst du fragen und ich zeige sie auch gleich tatsächlich funktioniert easy
wird camping im richtigen seitenverhältnis leute
das ist jetzt schon fast ein fall für akte x der wird camp hier
wir nehmen noch mal kurz hier das den den den
gatschi gatschi bassem gatschi bass alter wo wir jetzt haben wir nehmen wir nehmen
den vogel der passt eigentlich ganz ja funktioniert aber hier big brain chat
ich meine das kann man natürlich jetzt noch besser machen das problem ist ja
dass das überhaupt nicht re-sized aktuell also der der der hat hardcoded
1080p das mit dem re-sized muss ich mir angucken aber bevor ich das mit dem
re-sized machen kann muss ich das erstmal auf auf aufräumen ich mein das
ist ja nur einfach alles untereinander geschrieben und das nächste mal machen
wir auch einen fps counter dass wir sehen wie schnell das geht
5 spielgarten fps gif rendering leute das reicht für heute aber wir haben doch schon mal richtig massive
progress gemacht wir können gifs schnell rendern wir können gifs schneller
rendern als leute gifs sehen können das ist doch schon mal was also wir können gifs unsehbar
schnell rendern nicht dass man das brauchen würde und es ist auch nicht
sehen uns weg der sache aber es funktioniert so wie findest du writer im vergleich zu
visual studio co als visual studio ich finde den debugger angenehmer in visual studio vielleicht
vielleicht einfach weil ich die writer geschichte nicht so gewöhnt bin für die
bei aber ja der debugger gefällt mir besser von allem anderen ist mir writer lieber mittlerweile
visual studio ist mittlerweile krass langsam geworden ich weiß nicht was sie da bei microsoft
machen guckt euch das teilweise mal an du sagst sie irgendwie guck mal hier wie das das leckt
ihr merkt das jetzt nicht dieses das allein das fenster hier leckt ein bisschen schon
also da muss ich sagen ist mir writer eigentlich schon lieber wann ist der nächste stream morgen
wahrscheinlich das nächste studio ist 64 spät ja aber das wird dann wahrscheinlich nichts daran
ändern das wird wahrscheinlich nichts daran ändern writer ist auch oftmals nicht das schnellste
ich war mir dürfte nicht vergessen es ist eine java idee um sie scharf zu programmieren das
ist an sich ja schon irgendwie mal durch die brust ins auge der zwerg cringe er sagt er für den
writer die bugger besser ja kann kann schon sein dass der besser ist ich habe den einfach nicht so
oft benutzt was ich zum beispiel nicht check ist wo sie ich meinen ram verbrauch wo sich den ram
verbrauch hier memory muss ich den ram verbrauch und rechts in der was unten rechts in der leiste
rechts reinklicken du meinst hier unten die oder die ja moment das ist der ram verbrauch von writer
nicht der ram prog auf verbrauch von meinem programm oder ja moment das ist der ram verbrauch von
writer den meine ich nicht wer braucht einen debugger wenn es console writer gibt ja sehe
ich auch so ich bin auch console console debug verfechter das finde ich in visual studio halt
ganz schön du startest das und du siehst hier neben sofort ob du eine memory leak hast zumindest
was habe ich jetzt wieder kaputt gemacht was habe ich denn jetzt wieder kaputt gemacht guck mal wir
haben wieder ein ganz kleines memory leak ist kaum der rede wert lösche ich wieder irgendwas nicht
oder wie doch ich dispose den zweiten effekt jetzt weiß ich nicht woher der memory leak kommt jetzt
jetzt bin ich bin ich sicher woher der memory liegt kommt wir können testen ob der garbage
collector wir können testen ob es am garbage collector liegt aber glaube ich nicht glaube ich
nicht es ist einfach es liegt einfach eigentlich kam ja nur der faktor hinzu ja deswegen aber
darf jetzt ja nicht sein was liegt denn jetzt hier was habe ich dann was habe ich denn gemacht das
was liegt wo habe ich wo habe ich da jetzt den memory leak gebaut ich meine das sollte alles
disposed werden was ist noch mal weg ich habe eine idee das geht das liegt bestimmt an get
output image oder sowas ich habe doch gerade schon gc collect gemacht das hat nix gebracht
ok warum genau verursacht das hier bin schön in memory leak das hier wahrscheinlich kann das sein
kann das sein dass das hier vielleicht ja das war es easy das war es das hat geleakt
hat das nicht disposed aber auch doof implementiert oder mein ok ist halt alles native c gedöns
wofür ist das fall das ist ein pointer pointer die referenz wie heißt wie heißt das offiziell
pointer die referencing operator oder sowas also das hier ist ja nur ein zeiger auf den
speicherbereich mit information welcher typ das ist und mit dem feil greifst du halt auf
den arbeitsspeicher zu und rufst das zeug auf die referenzierung ja bei writer musst du die
bag nicht dran klicken um dabei memory was zu sehen hatte ich doch gerade oder habe ich mich
verklickt ich habe die bag gesagt die bag memory nur da steht nichts sagt ich soll
eine breakpoint setzen ich will aber kein breakpoint setzen dann nehme ich einfach
will studio als übertrieben viel ram fressen der debugger das ist cool ich glaube so ein
kleines memory leak haben immer noch aber das können wir erst sehen wenn ich noch mal den
garbage collector auflass aber leute es reicht für heute haben richtig progress gemacht funktioniert
ziemlich gut die zwar noch hässlich wie die nacht aus aber es geht schnell schneller auf
jeden fall als das alt also definitiv schneller als die alte wpf geschichte also immer gucken ob
der freiger am start ist eben war er noch da da ist er da ist er komische asia mmos wieder
da spiele ich übrigens mit am wochenende also wir reden den freiger der osten meldet sich
zurück also leute bis denn wir sehen uns tu